little correctness has got no room in
comedy there's no room for political
correctness it implies that you're going
to say something that is going to be
it's going to go over the line it's
going to be aggressive it's going to be
it's going to be upsetting it's gonna it
might be might imply something about
someone there's there's political
correctness and then there's just
outright hate stuff you know yes bigoted
comedy but political correctness has a
tendency to to jump the gun before you
get to bigotry political correctness has
no sense of humor so it doesn't know I
will mention guns in my act and and not
that this is political direct it's the
same sort of thing I'll say guns and
then the audience immediately feel the
audience get uptight because I've said
nothing but guns they don't know what
I'm going to say they have no idea they
got no clue and they jump on it so what
happens in a politically incorrect joke
as they hear the first part and they
stop listening so they don't know what
the goddamn joke is about I have little
or no time for it and and if you have
trouble with that what you do is you
laugh if you think a joke was mean or
bad or something it was politically
incorrect you still laugh at the joke
then you go huh and then you go oh that
was in later on you go that was bad I
was bad to laugh at that do it on your
own time I would go to a college campus
the last one I went to was Penn State
last year and it were may have been even
longer ago and Sandusky but they just
gone through the year of Sandusky and
Paterno my opening actually even done
Sandusky drug jokes about him and we
thought we can't do that because these
kids have just been you know and when
you got onstage you realize these kids
are shell-shocked because they're not
even laughing at what they normally
would laugh at afterwards when we
avoided the topic completely the the kid
who writes for the paper wrote that we
were you know
to put the weight but if we were pussies
for not talking about it so it doesn't
matter which way you go you're going to
lose some of the time I always take the
moment when it because when I'm on a
campus and I know where I'm in an area
where I know political correctness when
I go to those places and I tell a joke
and I know that they're not going to
laugh because they're going to think
it's politically incorrect I just go at
the audience
it's a moment which you can actually
teach them I think it's important to to
to at least make the attempt to get
across to them that they should enjoy
themselves because otherwise if we
continue to move in that direction is
just you know we're going to be living
between uptight and stupid and there'll
be no in-between